are you looking for a reason to return
to battlefield one well now might be a
good time as the spring update has
brought a bunch of new features and
weapons to the table I'm Matt and this
GameSpot news update is ready to team up
and run into battle the spring updates
marquee feature is platoons these
essentially function as clans allowing
you to form a group of players that are
represented by an emblem and tag each
platoon is limited to a hundred members
but each player can join up to ten
platoons the feature seems somewhat
limited at the moment but developer dice
says it will continue to expand and
improve it as time goes on there's also
a handful of new weapon variants which
actually look really cool we have more
information on this update but if you
want to keep up on all of her
battlefield one coverage then make sure
to hit those like and subscribe buttons
perhaps my favorite feature to come in
this update is spotting this lets a
medic signal to a downed teammate that
they're on their way to revive them not
knowing whether there's someone coming
to help you has always left me feeling
hopeless in this game and there's
nothing more frustrating than risking
your life for a downed player only to
have them respawn anyway you can check
out the rest of the features on GameSpot
calm but if you want to catch up on the
latest in battlefield one then check out
our video on every new weapon and tank
in the last expansion
[Music]